the FBI is investigating how a passenger
with the wrong ticket boarded a flight
from Los Angeles to Tokyo on the pon
Airways flight 175 returned to LAX after
the crew found a passenger was not
supposed to be on board the airline said
he is an American in his 20s the TSA
says he had a ticket for another similar
flight on United Airlines Don Dahler is
here with how the incident is raising so
many questions about security at the
airport on a lot of questions good
morning a day says there is no mandatory
regulation that forced his plane to turn
around but the airline defended the
decision but one aviation expert we
spoke to said the u-turn was not
necessary and may have even put fliers
at a greater risk when they called this
morning they said they're going to put
us at the 10:00 p.m. plate tonight the
decision to bring a a flight 175 back to
LAX on Tuesday night caused flyers on
Wednesday an entire day of travel it
said that flight was delayed like you
know seven hours the plane to Tokyo
turned around about four hours into the
trip after the crew discovered an
unauthorized passenger in what was
supposed to be a vacant seat one person
wasn't supposed to be on that flight
which don't they like scan something
according to the TSA the passenger was
ticketed for a different flight on
United he was traveling with his brother
who was ticketed for the A&A flight both
flights were scheduled to depart around
the same time thank you so much for
taking me on this awesome vacation Dave
supermodel Chrissy Teigen and her
husband actor and musician John Legend
were among the passengers sent back to
LAX I just need to know why we couldn't
have flown to Tokyo and settled this one
person's mistake there Teigen later
asked on Twitter an a told CBS News the
decision was made in consideration of
safety I don't see why they went all the
way back to Los Angeles
Denis Kelly is a former airline captain
he says the plane should have landed at
the nearest airport and solved the issue
as soon as possible to spend four hours
flying back to Los Angeles with the guy
on the airplane you don't really know
what's going on that's not the safest
way to go it missed a bunch of things up
and didn't hurt anyone
but it could have an a also issued an
apology on Twitter writing we failed to
deliver the customer service we strive
for
we welcome ongoing feedback to
understand how we can work to make this
right
the FBI says it has not charged the
unauthorized passenger well some of that
feedback did come from Chrissy Teigen
yes all right Don thank you very much